Rob warned you Jeff's just co-authored a
book called gray Lord what's it about
it's about judicial corruption in the
city of Chicago on a federal
investigation a sting operation that
exposed the situation how did the the
roots of this corruption in the city
what was the climate that allowed
corruption to begin in the court system
here Chicago has always been a one-party
town or at least since the 20s and the
democratic organization has controlled
absolutely every facet of the life on
all three branches of the government the
executive the legislative and the
judicial to become a judge in Cook
County you had to be slated by the
regular Democratic organization you got
slated by doing political work and
therein were the seeds for corruption I
think that it wasn't a very big step
from taking a call from alderman or a
committing them to actually taking money
to fix cases and of course this
investigation didn't get at that
underlying corruption the political
corruption the political fix it's
possible in the courts of Cook County
but only at the financial corruption
what's the time frame in but the time
period that this is the story covered
the investigation the federal
investigation of the Cook County Circuit
Court system began in 1979 and this
investigation I believe is still
continuing today what was it that
attracted if it had been going on for
such a long time as you described and it
was really so fundamental to the
political structure in the city what
what was it that finally got people
interested in investigating finding out
what was going on perhaps putting it
into it why'd you say for years and
years there had been it had been going
on and people have been aware of it in
the 70s when Jim Thompson presently the
governor of Illinois was the US Attorney
here he had begun an investigation
of the legislative branch convicted a
number of Chicago aldermen under with
expansive use of the federal mail fraud
statute I think that they just finally
got around to looking at the judiciary
now there had been a very highly
publicized case in Cook County in the
late 70s and involved a mafia hitman who
there were two eyewitnesses and that's
very rare in a case like this it would
actually seen a murder take place this
Hitman was acquitted and the state's
attorney at the time
Bernard Cary was extremely upset he'd
gone to the US Attorney's Office then at
about the same time a couple of
prosecutors from the county system had
moved over or one prosecutor had moved
over from the state's attorney's office
into the US Attorney's Office and was
very concerned about judicial corruption
and there were the seeds for the gray
Lord investigation now this
investigation involved FBI agents
masquerading as defendants as defense
attorneys prosecutors and in one case a
judge it was a massive massive sting
operation and that operation really
didn't take them very far it only got
three or four judges but about the same
time a Chicago lawyer reporter my
co-author Jim Toey
had done a major story on a phenomena
known as hustling in Illinois if you're
arrested and charged with a crime a
minor crime a bond is set you can post
10% of that bond with the court and
you're free now in many states there are
bail bond systems where you give a
bondsman 10% if the bond is $2,500 you
pay 250 to the bondsman well in the
early 60s Illinois had such a system and
it was corrupt and consequently the
legislature abolished it and put the
various counties into the bail bond
system so when you post bond you
get a bond slip a few years after
establishing this system the legislature
and all of its wisdom made those bond
slips negotiable instruments or at least
to the extent that a defendant could
endorse it payable directly to an
attorney
so that was the birth of the hustler
people would walk into court maybe
they'd been charged with shoplifting or
maybe a traffic offense or whatever and
they'd have a bond slipped in their hand
and what Jim Julie observed in 1980 when
he went out and looked at these branch
courts where the judges and court
personnel steering these defendants to
particular lawyers now at the time of
course we couldn't prove why they were
steering them but we knew that it wasn't
because the judges had great confidence
and the legal ability of these lawyers
after we ran this story the federal
government picked that up they checked
the bond Slippery funds because there
were records and and they were able to
show that these attorneys weren't paying
federal income taxes on all the money
that they were receiving and they were
ultimately able to persuade those
attorneys to testify against judges they
were paying off and that became the
major the centerpiece of operation gray
Lord what name come from the there are
different stories about where the name
came from
we were told initially in fact the US
attorney the recent US attorney dan Webb
told me that gray Lord was a sarcastic
reference to the English Lord
Chancellor's and that's the English
spelling of gray as you will see someone
said more recently that actually there
was a racehorse named gray Lord the hen
that they just pulled the name out of
them out of the air
I don't really know there are different
perceptions you've made some reference
in the early chapters about the FBI
being predisposed towards sting
operations at the time we talked yes yes
sting operations are obviously they draw
great amount of publicity they get heavy
coverage on television in the newspapers
and I think the FBI
grew enamored of those in the in the 70s
a J Edgar Hoover
at one point supposedly had prohibited
them or had very greatly limited them
believing that they were not really an
effective use of law enforcement but
this took off right after Abscam which
of course was you know the FBI just got
all of this wonderful publicity and it
seems in almost every sting operation
they conducted had to be just a little
bit bigger and a little bit better than
the one previously and this was going to
be the granddaddy of them all operation
gray Lloyd
unfortunately the sting portions of it
didn't really work all that well I think
only three judges were actually
convicted as a result of the sting and
the FBI agents this involved setting up
phony cases to run them through the
system so for instance the FBI would
stage a strong armed robbery in which
the victim would be an FBI agent and the
robber would be an FBI agent they staged
one right down on Michigan Avenue on the
Magnificent Mile right in front of
Marshall Field and company one day and
the they waited until there was a police
officer nearby and the robber starts
running and the victim chases him and
ultimately tackles him and the police
arrested him well suddenly people were
arriving on the scene and they were
volunteering to testify saying I saw the
whole thing
while the police knew that this isn't
the way real one goes down furthermore
when they got them by over to the police
station to book him they searched him
and pulled out his wallet and lo and
behold he was carrying his FBI
identification card in another case the
FBI had telephoned an anonymous tip to
the police on Northwest side that a man
was sitting in a restaurant with a
satchel full of cocaine the police
walked in here was the man just as the
anonymous caller had described they
walked up to him and said what's in the
bag cocaine just like that
well police got why is that things don't
really happen
quite like that and so the police then
had to be taken in on the investigation
they had to be assured that they weren't
the targets of whatever the FBI was
doing and they were and so they
established a few more that they really
did get cases into the system except
it's extremely costly very hard to do in
the first place we had more than 300
judges in the Cook County Circuit Court
at that time and they sat in various
divisions but the assignments the case
assignments were random so if you
suspected that a judge was crooked even
if you staged a case you had no way of
assuring that it would get assigned to
the judge where you wanted to attempt to
make the payoff the there are other
problems I mean for instance they had an
FBI agent Ram a car into a light post
and he poured liquor all over himself
and and had just enough so there would
be some on his breath the police came it
was close to the end of a shift and they
didn't want to go through the paperwork
so they just threw the guy's keys down
the gutter and poured the booze out and
sent him home so they go through all of
these elaborate things and then
sometimes it would all come to naught
because it simply wouldn't work is that
sort of a side story to your book or do
you hope also to show that these kind of
operations by the FBI aren't the best
way to go about it my personal view is
that it really isn't an efficient way to
investigate corruption that's not the
point
no no no I mean there was certainly was
and I believe continues today to be very
serious corruption in the circuit court
of of Cook County and this investigation
has certainly gone a long way toward
making the people who are engaged in
that very uncomfortable was not rooting
it out entirely the book seems to have a
number of villains and when I read one
review and it said it reads like a novel
one of the things that strikes you is
really how latent some of the the the
actions were how some of the quotes are
all most outrageous almost as if they
were written by a Hollywood script
writer as opposed to well yes now you
understand that
course these things came out in the
trials and these weren't things that you
are I could go into a courtroom and
observe if you were looking like I mean
Wayne Olsen one of the judges who was
convicted saying I like people that take
dough because you know where they stand
or judge Ramon's so Dini
when he saw court personnel in the back
of his courtroom who appeared to be
bickering over splitting up payoffs that
they'd received from an attorney he told
his bailiff go tell those guys if
they're talking about money to go in the
back room and do it not to talk about it
you know out here in the open well all
of those kinds of things came out actual
testimony in trials but they weren't
something that we could have observed
his journalists or any other person who
just comes into the court could see now
you could see a lot of things that were
going on but Jim Tory and I have been
covering the courts in Cook County
off and on for more than 20 years and if
you had asked me to come testify before
a grand jury I wouldn't have a single
incident that I could ever have related
which is why it takes a massive federal
investigation of this sort to root it
out where the victims and stories like
this well of course we the citizens are
the ultimate victims if they're if the
justice system is corrupted we're
victims in a number of ways obviously if
the drunk driver isn't fined or
something we're financially hurt but
that's a minor part of it I think that
it you know it breeds disrespect for the
law that in it creates more lawlessness
than we would otherwise have and the
Cook County Circuit Court had the
reputation of being corrupt and has the
reputation today of being corrupt and I
think that's the real
damage that's done by these appearances
that justice is not done or that a case
can be fixed some judges can be wired
and another aspect of this corruption
just because of the reputation of the
system the average person who was
charged with a misdemeanor believed that
the system was corrupt so if a lawyer
said to him well my fee will be $500 and
then comes back right before the trial
or usually a bench trial and says well
we're gonna have to pay off the judge
it'll be another 250 it was a way that
it just enabled lawyers to extort money
in that way that was called rainmaking
by the people who engaged in it that is
telling the client that the lawyer was
going to pay a bribe but actually of
course just pocketing the money and it
was possible simply because of the
reputation of the system
interestingly lawyers could tell I mean
of course because of the the practice
that this is the evidence maybe a
witness is not going to show up or the
evidence is very weak
the defendants going to be acquitted for
sure the lawyer would know and so you
could do this with a great deal of
certainty but in a case where the lawyer
was surprised if the judge heard the
evidence and said no I find the
defendant guilty the lawyer would then
go back and say she who have you upset
in the prosecutor's office there was
tremendous heat in this case and the
judge just couldn't do it here's your
money back
in most cases were we talking about
large sums of money when some cases we
were talking about oh five hundred a
thousand dollars but in most cases and
in some cases we were talking about
extremely small amounts of money I think
one of the things that amazed observers
in Chicago was not that the corruption
was so rife but that justice was being
sold for so little some in some cases as
little as ten dollars a case
early on in your book he tells story
struck me of one particular judge who
occasionally didn't want to come to
court oh yes we tell it well that's
judge sadena who ran a he presided over
a gambling court at Central Police
Headquarters and early in the morning he
had to handle what's called the bum call
this is the call of all of the people
who were swept off the streets basically
for safekeeping
on any given night in Chicago they're
all brought in well judge Cedeno who
drank a lot would sometimes have a
hangover in the morning and he'd call in
and tell his bailiff to tell the police
sergeant assigned to his courtroom to
put on the robes and do the bum call so
the police sergeant would literally put
on the judges robes sit there and go
through this call and these defendants
were all just dismissed they were
charged with them an offense known as
disorderly conduct which is really not
much of an offense they're more
disheveled and and pathetic and
disorderly and they're all released but
one of the stories that we told here one
day a drunk was being particularly
boisterous in the back and they saved
his case until last and brought him in
and sentenced him to death that was a
rather unsettling way for him to begin
the day I would suspect talked about the
victims and certainly the many villains
isn't wearing this tree are there any
heroes are there any good guys in this
book well I would say the best guy was a
Chicago lawyer named Keith Davis who
when we did our initial expose on
hustling in 1981 was the person who went
around to the courtrooms with us showed
us what was going on sort of exposed a
lot of the conduct that ultimately
became the central piece of gray Lord
the prosecutors by and large we're
sweeper tre is very politically
ambitious people I think a lot of them
were
well-motivated did a very good job and
we're certainly not anti heroes but I
mean they were just doing their job to
me Keith Davis would be the hero of Grey
Lord and you and mr. - we were working
where at the time I caught a lawyer I'd
say it's a monthly publication that it's
now 11 years old and we've done
investigations into corruption than the
judiciary in the legal profession for
for these ten years and that's where we
why we got onto this story so early on
and we were able to find out so much
about it how long was it before the
city's major daily newspapers were
writing about it regularly they didn't
write about it regularly until the US
government began to leak it leaks from
the prosecutor's office that this
investigation was going on and then of
course it was banner headlines but that
wasn't until 84 83 or 84 why can you
knowing how the system works how
government sometimes tries to influence
the media like why was the Justice
Department leaking the story at that
point but what did they see as a as an
end to be served they wanted to this is
my view I mean they would they would
dispute this but I think that they
wanted to create a general feeling of
paranoia among the people who were under
investigation and get them to come
forward and cooperate furthermore the
story had actually begun to leak to some
of the targets they had served a
subpoena on one of the lawyers who had
been involved in payoffs to judges he
had been to a defense lawyer and so they
knew it was just a matter of time until
it was going to to leak and they
controlled it very well they they leaked
it to very specific people and resulted
in massive international publicity
months and months and months before the
first indictments came down
in the early days before the popular
press got involved in there was this
ever a dangerous story for you to write
oh I don't think so
no I I don't think that you know most of
the judges involved here in this
corruption not all of them but most of
them were really rather pathetic they
had bad alcohol habits they were
alcoholics what many of them were doing
was just taking enough money to support
a good drinking habit you know 50 $100 a
day to pay the bar bill at night and no
I don't think there was any danger that
anybody was going to be killed or
anything like that and there were
certainly no threats that came to our
attention in the end out of both a sting
operation in the end the larger
investigation
how many indictments how many
convictions there were 86 or 87
indictments and virtually they have all
been convicted with two exceptions and
among those are 14 judges and the rest
are court personnel and lawyers when you
look at the sentences what was the
attitude by the judicial system in in
policing its own you got white sentences
heavy sentences food oh I think they
were extremely heavy I think that the
the sentences were were very heavy in
fact I think the federal judiciary when
it came to dealing with this problem was
appalled and many federal judges of
course came out of the state system and
where they were generally genuinely
appalled by what they found
yeah you indicate that that it continues
the corruption continues there has
unfortunately there's been no systemic
change in the system it continues to
operate pretty much like it did in the
past now this practice of hustling I
mean that's largely gone it was to a
parent and to open but whatever the
underlying problems were which I believe
stemmed from the political selection of
judges the lack of Independence of the
branch of government from the other two
branches that the possibility the
political fix that remains it's as
prevalent today as it ever was
we've driven some of the worst crooks I
think off the bench and and people are a
lot more subtle but this is not the end
of judicial corruption in Cook County
what's it going to take for a systemic
change well first I think we'd have to
change the system in which the chief
judges chosen he's presently elected by
the other judges of the court the ones
he's supposed to be supervising now
that's not really much of a very good
management structure as I'm sure
absolutely every management consultant
in the world would agree the other is
that we need to change the way in which
judges are chosen
we need a it's called a merit selection
system we need to replace this political
selection process with a merit selection
system now those are the two biggest
steps that could be taken and of course
neither of those has been taken where do
you see an impetus for a change like
that coming from
if this investigation and the massive
publicity couldn't do it I don't know
what really could in recent years
however it's been rather interesting to
observe that the democratic organization
has lost control it's no longer the
monolithic force in Chicago that it once
was
in 1984 the Democratic slated candidates
for judge were defeated by people who
happen to have Irish names this is a big
Irish City and so if your name is Kelly
or O'Malley you have a very good shot
and a much better shot than someone with
a non Irish name with a and it just
turned out that in 1984 the organization
or the Machine slated people with non
Irish names they
opponents who had Irish names or more
Irish sounding names and they won it's
sort of you know left me with the view
that the only person who could favor the
present system is an anarchist because
there are the organization can't control
it anymore
so ultimately when the organization
loses control and the politicians
understand that they've lost control
perhaps we can have a meaningful reform
but this investigation didn't bring that
amount mm-hmm why did you and James to
decide to turn this into a book what we
just thought it was one heck of a story
it's got the elements of Guys and Dolls
it's got tragic elements comic elements
and it's an important story that had
never been told and there was no other
way one of the reviews said that gee
there's very little new here there's no
new research most of this had been
published before in various publications
including our own and that's true but
there was no place for that it was all
pulled together and that's what we
thought we could do in this book is this
a peculiarly Chicago story are there
lessons for the country to learn from
this I would hope that it's not as bad
anywhere else in the country as it was
or is in Chicago but just like police
corruption is not a purely Chicago
phenomena it exists everywhere
I assume that this exists to some extent
in every large metropolitan area talked
a little bit about the federal judiciary
being outraged by this do you know for
sure or have any sense that it is
encouraging some review of the process
in other cities around the country I
really have no idea except of course the
reform there the bar the organized bar
has become increasingly concerned with
ethics appearances and I think it's
probably having an effect everywhere but
I don't really have any first-hand
knowledge of what's going on anywhere
except in Chicago if you and James - it
could write an epilogue to grey law in a
few years from now what would you hope
that would be I would I would hope that
we could find more heroes I would hope
that we could that we could find someone
who would be the hero of the sequel I'd
I'd like to find at least one good
honest person in the system to make a
hero and unfortunately we didn't have
that this time that we'll have to wait
for the sequel and in addition to that
ultimately that the system will be
reformed as well or have you given up
hope on that well I would hope that the
system would be reformed and that that's
why we would have a hero who finally
brought this about what did you learn by
writing the book anything yes you always
learn things when even if you before you
actually start writing something it
helps you know clarify the thought
process that's why I see sometimes
courts issue decisions and say that a
written opinion will follow I think that
that's wrong because I think the writing
process is what clarifies that opinion
and the thought process and you in the
writing process you run against problems
that hadn't occurred to you or that you
hadn't focused on quite as well and you
learn a great deal and I think that at
one point it just really dawned on me
how thoroughly corrupt this entire
system was I mean we had judges who were
popping off the bench to take payoffs in
the middle of trials we had in one case
a lawyer who was literally involved and
if you invited him to dinner at your
house he cased the joint for his burglar
friends he wants to set up a
money-laundering scheme for
some friends of his and he changed some
Gold Krugerrands for cash for them in
his office and arranged to have them hit
in the and mugged in the lobby of his
building
we had prosecutors who were authorizing
the bugging of clients by lawyers I mean
to me this is just just thoroughly a
thoroughly distasteful thing that was
exposed here and it really having
covered it for all these years writing
this book brought that all into focus
for me Rob Bourdon